zdf heute live herzlich willkommen die
tat hat deutschlandweit für große
bestürzung gesorgt die tödlichen schüsse
gestern morgen auf zwei polizisten in
der nähe des rheinland-pfälzischen orts
kusel noch am selben tag wurden zwei
tatverdächtige festgenommen heute sollen
sie dem haftrichter vorgeführt werden
über den aktuellen stand der
ermittlungen berichten polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft in wenigen minuten in
einer pressekonferenz bis es soweit ist
sprechen wir mit meinem kollegen vor ort
mit bobby cherry an er ist in
kaiserslautern
bobby zwei tatverdächtige also werden
heute dem richter vorgeführt was ist
bislang über diese männer bekannt
wir melden uns hier aus kaiserslautern
und jederzeit könnte jetzt die
pressekonferenz losgehen über die zwei
männer ist erstmal das alter bekannt ein
mann 38 jahre alt ein mann 32 jahre alt
der eine wurde ja gestern auch
namentlich zur fahndung ausgeschrieben
andreas es aus dem saarland dem kreis
neunkirchen dort wurde er in sulzbach
gestern auch festgenommen nachdem er
sich über seine anwältin gestellt hatte
das sind die beiden tatverdächtigen zu
dem zweiten tatverdächtigen dem 32
jährigen ist jetzt nicht allzu viel
bekannt über den tatverdächtigen andreas
es weiß man dass er wild händler ist und
das in seinem haus auch waffen gefunden
worden sind der stand heute vormittag
lautete noch dass beide tatverdächtige
sich bisher nicht zu der eigentlichen
tat geäußert haben so wie wenn es
losgeht dann bist du natürlich sofort
drinnen bei der pressekonferenz wir
wollen aber für unser publikum noch
einmal die ereignisse des gestrigen
tages zusammenfassen das macht meine
kollegin anna güter
heute vormittag am polizeipräsidium
westpfalz trauerbeflaggung für die
erschossenen polizisten
sie starben hier an der kreisstraße 22
am tatort sollen ermittler papiere eines
verdächtigen gefunden haben darauf
nahmen spezialeinheiten der polizei im
saarländischen sulzbach zwei männer fest
darunter den 38 jährigen andreas es aus
dem saarland wir gingen davon aus dass
sich die 38-jährige tatverdächtige nach
dem wir auch öffentlich gefahndet haben
hier aufhält das hat sich schlussendlich
auch bestätigt und der mann konnte von
spezialeinheiten rheinland pfalz und
saarland hier widerstandslos
festgenommen werden der tatort heute
mittag die jungen polizeibeamten führten
gestern hier eine verkehrskontrolle
durch sie sollen per funk gemeldet haben
in einem fahrzeug sei totes wild
gefunden worden später folgten die
polizisten sie schießen danach brach der
kontakt ab die brutale tat sorgt
bundesweit für entsetzen der
bundeskanzler twittert was in kusel
passiert es bedrückt mich sehr mein
mitgefühl gilt den angehörigen der
beiden jungen opfer ich denke an die
vielen polizistinnen die jeden tag ihr
leben riskieren um uns bürger innen zu
schützen die hintergründe der tat sind
weiterhin völlig unklar
beide tatverdächtige werden heute dem
ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt
die hintergründe sind noch unklar
über das motiv kannst du bist dann auch
noch nichts weiteres sagen
tatsächlich gibt es dazu bislang keine
informationen
es war ja tatsächlich auch so dass
gestern vor ort in kusel wo wir ja auch
waren die informationen von der polizei
spärlich bis überhaupt nicht geflossen
sind zwar gab es immer wieder
möglichkeiten in kaiserslautern
informationen einige zu bestätigen aber
tatsächlich diese großen fragen darauf
gab es tatsächlich gestern noch keine
rückschlüsse und dazu gehört eben auch
die motivlage es gab diverse
medienberichte eben wie im beitrag auch
erwähnt wurde dass die beiden beamten
die 24 jährige polizistin und ihr 29
jähriger kollegin kollege durch gegeben
hätten sie hätten wild in einem fahrzeug
gefunden aber das ist zum gestrigen
zeitpunkt auch von der polizei selber
nicht bestätigt worden sondern es hieß
immer nur aus sicherheitskreisen und den
tathergang den ganzen verlauf und
tatsächlich auch etwas mehr über die
motive zu erfahren das soll natürlich
jetzt hoffentlich gleich in der
pressekonferenz geschehen kann man denn
noch mal rekapitulieren die festnahme
wie die abgelaufen ist da hat es ja
offenbar keinen großen widerstand
gegeben
nach dem was jetzt bekannt ist gab es
wohl zwei faktoren die da maßgeblich
waren der erste ist das so wurde gestern
gemeldet die papiere des tatverdächtigen
andreas es am tatort gefunden worden
sind das ließ dann einige spekulationen
zu dahingehend wie diese papiere dort
wohin gekommen sind oder vielleicht in
welchem prozess im zusammenspiel mit den
beiden getöteten polizisten und dann war
es so dass sich andreas es über seine
anwältin der polizei gestellt hat der
zweite tatverdächtige der 32-jährige
mann von dem eigentlichen ist der
beschuldigung damit nahtlos mit der
pressekonferenz erfahre ich gerade genau
danke für die antworten bis hierhin wir
gehen rüber und schauen was dort auf der
pressekonferenz gesagt wird und das
machen wir diesen moment bitte schön
diese morde machen uns fassungslos und
trotz unserer großen betroffenheit
arbeiten wir seit gestern morgen
gemeinsam mit unseren kolleginnen
kollegen aus dem saarland unseren
spezial anhalten und weiteren
unterstützungskräften untersagt leitung
der staatsanwaltschaft in kaiserslautern
an der bestmöglichen aufklärung dieser
brutalen taten
die beiden beamten waren nicht nur
unsere kollegen sie waren freunde
vertraute und wegbegleiter in gedanken
sind wir bei der getöteten kollegen und
ihren kollegen aber auch bei ihren
familien und freunden den ich auch von
dieser stelle aus mein herzliches
beileid aussprechen wir werden hier
jetzt vor uns liegenden schweren stunden
und tage gemeinsam mit den familien
gehen
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich will
auch ein anderes thema kurz an sprechen
wir erleben momentan auch eine unfassbar
große welle der solidarität und
anteilnahme
neben polizeibehörden und andere
sicherheitsorganisationen
haben sich auch zahlreiche
privatpersonen und organisationen aus
dem gesamten bundesgebiet
auch aus unseren europäischen
nachbarländern bei uns gemeldet und
ihrer bestimmung bestürzend getan
und grüße an die familien
weihnachtsgrüße und die hinterbliebenen
gebeten auszurüsten sie sind in gedanken
auch mit uns
bevor wir jetzt zum thema kommen des
heutigen nachmittags wir wollen ihnen ja
berichten über die abläufe die wir seit
gestern morgen im 422 haben möchte ich
ihnen kurz die kolleginnen kollegen am
tisch vorstellen zu meiner linken sitzt
herr polizeivizepräsident heiner schmolz
der seit gestern morgen die
einsatzführung über den laufenden
sondereinsatz wahrnimmt
der kriminaldirektor frank otte auf der
linie äußeren seite ist der leiter der
kriminaldirektion kaiserslautern
erleidet die den bereich ermittlungen
und der steht nachher für fragen zu
einzelheiten zur verfügung von
landespolizeipräsidium des saarlandes
begrüße ich frau melanie morbach ich
habe ich ja eben schon eingangs erwähnt
das saarland hat uns sehr unterstützt
bei allen maßnahmen die in den letzten
stunden stattgefunden haben und
sehr gerne stelle ich auch meinen
nachbarn freunde und leitender
oberstaatsanwalt dr gehring und ein
oberstaatsanwalt orten die sache hatten
die staatsanwaltschaft vertreten
und auch für fragen zur verfügung stehen
ich würde das wort dann auch begrüßt
wurde und sie müssen doch da gehring und
bitte sie dann übernommen
vielen dank
herzlich willkommen zu dieser
pressekonferenz ein paar das selber
sieht um bestenfalls bedanke ich mich
für die organisation in den räumen der
justiz im forum der justiz
und bei ihnen
damen und herren medienvertretern
bedanke ich mich für das große interesse
es reflektiert man sich nach die
persönliche betroffenheit sehr viele
bürger angesichts des todes von jungen
polizeibeamten
die in ausübung ihres dienstes gestorben
sind weil erfüllung ihrer aufgabe
unserer sicherheit zu garantieren und
unsere gesetze durchzusetzen
ich werde nachher noch allgemein etwas
zu sagen und geben und nunmehr zunächst
an den vize polizeipräsidenten weiter
der die verhandlung referieren wird
jetzt ok
also der vorletzten nacht war unserer
polizeiinspektion in kusel in der
bekämpfung von eigentumskriminalität
unterwegs und man hat der
fahndungsmaßnahmen kontrollmaßnahmen
vorgesehen für eine person dort die in
der eigentumskriminalität
unterwegs ist im bereich kusel die durch
ein ros fluchtverhalten bisher
aufgefallen ist für die auf die aber
keinen hinweis auf waffen bisher vorlag
deshalb hat man sich entschieden ein
einsatzkonzept zu fahren mit einem
zivilfahrzeug in zwei funkstreifenwagen
und üblicherweise haben eine solche
situation hat das zivilfahrzeug die
aufgabe aufklärung zu betreiben und die
eigentliche kontrolle wird dann
üblicherweise von der funkstreife der
jeweilige dann durchgeführt
von 1932 bis 20 17 kam es dann zu einem
funkspruch
der beiden getöteten beamtinnen des
beamten dass sie dubiose personen
festgestellt hätten im bereich it und
der ganzen kofferraum sei voller
wildtiere sie haben doch dann noch
unterstützung durch andere durch die
beiden anderen fahrzeuge angefordert
von 20 17 bis 21 uhr acht würde gefunkt
kommen schnell diese diese kommen
schnell wir sind zwischen ulm at und
40 12 ausgleichen jedes bach wir kommen
das war das letzte was dann gefunkt
wurde daraufhin war noch ein schuss zu
hören die etwa zehn minuten später
eintrafen dann unterstützungskräfte
haben dann die kollegin vor dem
zivilfahrzeug gefunden sie war bereits
tot der beamte wurde gefunden hinter dem
zivilfahrzeug im bereich einer böschung
und war auch schwerst verletzt und nicht
mehr ansprechbar
ein fahrzeug war der vor ort nicht
festgestellt
am tatort waren spuren die gesehen wurde
und es wurde ein führerschein und ein
bundespersonalausweis
gefunden neben der getöteten kollegin
beide papiere waren ausgestellt auf den
zwischenzeitlich festgenommenen 38
jährigen tatverdächtigen aus dem
saarland
daraufhin eingeleitete polizeieinsatz
hat sich dann auf die fahndungsmaßnahmen
in richtung saarland konzentriert wir
haben hier beim pp west falls wir nennen
das eine besondere aufbauorganisation
aufgebaut eine arbeitsstruktur mit dem
wir diesen sachverhalt abarbeiten
wollten das sind die kernaufgaben sind
da verhandlungen sind ermittlungen und
sind natürlich auch der einsatz unserer
spezialeinheiten wegen der besonderheit
saarland haben wir auch ganz schnell
kontakt mit dem saarland aufgenommen und
haben mit dem dortigen polizeiführer der
polizei trug der schweizer auch die
arbeitsstrukturen für den tag abgestimmt
und geplant
im weiteren verlauf wurden durch
verschiedenen feststellungen wäre
objekte im saarland als mögliche ziele
objekte identifiziert es wurden
verschiedene kontaktpersonen bekannt und
es wurden auch hinweise auf
verschiedenste fahrzeuge bekannt die von
beschuldigen genutzt werden könnten
diesen hinweisen sind wir zusammen mit
den kollegen aus dem saarland die ist da
tatkräftig unterstützt haben
nachgegangen und im laufe des tages
konnte sich da auch ein fahndungserfolg
einstellung über den die kollegin
morbacher aus dem saarland nun berichten
wird
als klar war dass der tatverdächtige im
saarland gewohnt haben wir mehrere
zielobjekte und fahrzeuge in sein land
natürlich überprüft und auch mit
verschiedenen personen kontakt
aufgenommen in zusammenarbeit mit den
kollegen aus rheinland pfalz
im laufe des nachmittags haben sich dann
zwei wohnobjekte in sulzbach sowie ein
fahrzeug heraus kristallisiert und
es wurde festgestellt dass sich der
38-jährige tatverdächtige nach dem zu
diesem zeitpunkt bereits öffentlich
gefahndet wurde vermutlich in sulzbach
im bereich der bahnhofstraße aufhält die
kräfte wurden dann dorthin verlagert und
die spezialkräfte waren natürlich steht
auch im einsatz rheinland pfalz und
saarland
als der 38-jährige tatverdächtige gegen
17 uhr dann das wohngebäude verlassen
hat konnte ein zugriff erfolgen und er
wurde von den spezialeinheiten
festgenommen
der 38 jährige ließ sich widerstandslos
festnehmen
das haben sich dann natürlich noch
durchsuchungen in den wohnungen
angeschlossen und dabei trafen wir auf
eine weitere person und zwar in 32
jährigen aus sulzbach bei ihm handelt
sich um einen weiteren möglichen
tatverdächtigen
und er wurde ebenfalls loher ebenfalls
widerstandslos festgenommen
ich würde das wort dann nochmal
bezüglich weiterer ermittlungsmaßnahmen
an den kollegen schmolze übergeben
die staatsanwaltschaft war ja war ja ein
gescheiter kindern hat die ganzen
maßnahmen auf den ganzen tag begleitet
und was dann mit den beiden festgenommen
was passiert ist was geschehen ist da
will ich dann doch das war dann die
justiz übergeben
meine damen und herren
gegen die zwei tatverdächtigen von denen
schon die ganze zeit die rede ist den
38-jährigen den 32-jährigen der
ermittlungsrichter beim amtsgericht
kaiserslautern
haftbefehl erlassen diese beiden
haftbefehle wurden heute morgen eröffnet
und in vollzug gesetzt so dass sich die
beiden beschuldigten seither in
untersuchungshaft
befinden
in dem oder in diesen beiden
haftbefehlen geht der ermittlungsrichter
davon aus dass die beiden
tatverdächtigen die beiden jungen
polizeibeamten gemeinschaftlich getötet
haben
zur vorgeschichte lässt sich der aktuell
auch aus der ermittlungsrichter geht
davon aus dass die beiden
tatverdächtigen
in einem
fahrzeug in einem kastenwagen im kreis
kusel unterwegs waren um dort zu wildern
man hat dann später bei der festnahme
auch dieses fahrzeug gefunden und dann
befand sich noch eine große anzahl von
erlegten wildtieren
in der ladefläche des kastenwagens
und der haftbefehl geht weiter davon aus
dass die beiden tatverdächtigen die
beiden beschuldigten dann in diese
verkehrskontrolle gerieten die beiden
polizeibeamten waren uniformiert und
haben sich auch als polizeibeamte zu
erkennen gegeben jedenfalls gehen wir
davon aus
und es gibt noch diesen ersten
funkspruch aus dem zu entnehmen ist dass
man diese wildtiere auf der ladefläche
oder im kofferraum warum ladefläche des
kastenwagens festgestellt hat und nun zu
einer personenkontrolle übergehen will
und der nächste punkt spruch ist ja
schon erwähnt worden kurz danach ist
einen hilferuf und
eine mitteilung dass die auf uns
gemeinsam die polizeibeamten schießen
würden
im moment gehen wir davon aus nach dem
die gerichtsmedizin erste untersuchungen
vorgenommen hat und man bei diversen
durchsuchungen auch waffen gefunden hat
die die tatwerkzeuge sein könnten
dass einer der beiden waffe an eine
schrotflinte ist und die andere waffe
ein jagdgewehr ein sogenannter einlader
der einzelnen aufmunitioniert werden
muss
und diese vermutung deckt sich auch mit
dem verletzungsbild dass man den opfern
festgestellt hat im moment gehen wir
also davon aus dass mindestens zwei
waffen verwendet wurden und wir gehen
auch davon aus dass diese zwei waffen
von den beiden beschuldigten genutzt
wurden also dass jeder geschossen hat
bei der getöteten polizeibeamten führte
ein schuss mit der
waffe zu tödlichen verletzungen
der ähnliche polizeibeamte wurde
insgesamt viermal getroffen
es besteht der haftgrund der
fluchtgefahr
gegen die beiden beschuldigten
der ermittlungsrichter geht davon aus
dass die tat
gemeinschaftlichen mord darstellt
dass diese tötung der beiden
polizeibeamten dazu diente die
vorangegangene jagdwilderei zu verdecken
und
dass deswegen das mordmerkmal der
verdeckungsabsicht erfüllt ist
vor diesem hintergrund ist im
wesentlichen auch dann der haftgrund der
fluchtgefahr begründet
zumal bei beiden beschuldigten
festzustellen war nach dem bisherigen
ergebnis der ermittlungen dass ihre
wirtschaftlichen verhältnisse alles
andere als geordnet sind und dass auch
ihre sozialen verhältnisse eher brüchig
sind und dass dies alles die
straferwartung und ihre persönlichen
verhältnisse ihre persönliche
lebenssituation dazu geführt haben dass
der ermittlungsrichter fluchtgefahr
begründet hat
die beiden haftbefehle sind dann vollzug
gesetzt und sie befinden sich in
untersuchungshaft
vielen dank die pole zeit also in sehr
kurzer zeit mit einer beantworten
kraftanstrengung vieles ermittelt aber
die ns ermittlungsverfahren ist noch am
anfang wir werden alles tun um das
geschehen so weit wie möglich
aufzuklären und die gesetzlichen
konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen
die richter möchte ebenfalls erwähnen
die einen dieser phase des verfahrens im
hintergrund sind als rechtsmäßigkeit
kontrolle aber mit demselben
pflichtbewusstsein ihrer aufgabe
nachkommen
gegenstand ermittlung wird sein
insbesondere wer genau was zu der tat
beigetragen hat und was die motive waren
es gehört nicht zu unserer vorstellung
von deutschland
dass jemand auf offener straße mit
jagdwaffen anfängt zu schießen und das
feuer eröffnet bloß weil er vielleicht
noch wildern erwischt hat deswegen ist
der fast verstörend
oder sagen justiz allerdings öfter mit
unwahrscheinlichen ereignissen zu tun
seltene und unwahrscheinliche ereignisse
das ein bisschen geradezu unser job ich
möchte ja den blick auf eine gemeinsame
aufgabe von polizei und justiz richten
und auf ein gemeinsames prinzip
nachdem ihr vorgehen das
legalitätsprinzip das heißt dass wir uns
nicht aussuchen können womit wir uns
befassen
sondern die gesetze durchsetzen müssen
auch wenn das unangenehm und gefährlich
ist
an dieser stelle möchte ich deshalb
meinen respekt so ausdrücken für die
polizei und insbesondere für die beiden
getöteten polizeibeamten
die sie diese aufgabe unterziehen
als stars wirtschaft zieht man die was
die polizei tut was sie jetzt in den
akten man sich solche zusammenarbeit
aber wie es meistens aus der
ego-perspektive und mit einer gewissen
distanz weil wir nicht dann weiß sind
das ganze dann nachträglich würdigen
aber deswegen kann ich eben sagen
die ich sehe dabei dann aber der polizei
eine kultur der vernunft und eine kultur
der höflichkeit was das verhältnis der
bürger betrifft
und ich bring das nicht zusammen mit mit
dem
blinden hass der manchmal den organen
entgegenschlägt
ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
länder hast dich ja zu einem
gesellschaftlichen problem geworden ist
da ist ja nicht durch die polizei
provoziert wird nicht durch das
verhalten polizei provoziert sondern
eine andere ursache hat die wir angehen
müssen
jetzt aber zurück zum fall da möchte ich
noch mal darauf zurückkommen auf ein
anderes und auf ein anderes prinzip das
auch unsere arbeit regelt das ist dass
die einzelfallgerechtigkeit
wir sind die am anfang der ermittlungen
es ist völlig klar etwas ja schon was
ist passiert
die frage wer in welchem umfang dafür
verantwortlich ist ist aber noch
gegenstand der ermittlungen
wir befinden uns in einem frühen stadium
des verfahrens wir werden das aufklären
und fertigte daraus ziehen und dann
ermittelten fakten der öffentlichkeit
mitteilen
auch kriegsführung finden dürfen die
stadt so dass sich jeder wenn die fakten
dann vorliegen die verfügbar sind eine
meinung bilden kann
einziges beispiel von von verfrühten
schlüssel möchte ich noch erwähnen es
gibt einen zeugen der genauso alt ist
wie einer der beschuldigten und der
offenbar probleme hat wie mitgeteilt
wurde weil er verwechselt wird
das möchte ich noch mal auf den nach dem
weg geben das also
was weiß ich schon vergewissern was man
was an berichtet und welche schlüsse
daraus zieht
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit ich
würde dann an den
erfurt weitergeben für viele fragen
nein da haben sie mich falsch verstanden
es war ich habe die genauen die genaue
minuten noch mal das dach ist war 4 uhr
19 32 24 17
ja das war die zeit dieses ersten
funkspruch
haben das falsche
beschuldigung
ja und das ist der zweite funkspruch der
war von 24 17 bis 24 08 und ganz genau
zu sein
die beiden tatverdächtigen
waffenbesitzkarten besessen haben bei
dem 38-jährigen heißt ja dass 2008 und
2020 jeweils
waffenbesitzkarte einkassiert worden
seid und 32 jährigen liegen dass keiner
information zu können die dazu etwas
sagen
ja also wir sind momentan noch in den
abklärungen bezüglich waffenbesitzkarten
auch bezüglich den berechtigungsschein
zur ausübung von eventuellen jagd
berechtigungen ich kann hierzu heute
noch keine detaillierten fakten nennen
wie gesagt dass sie mir noch in den
abklärungen und belastbares material zu
erlangen
eingesetzt waren ihm zusammen haben mit
der aufklärung von eigentumsdelikt
entstanden die in irgendeinem
zusammenhang mit den dringend
tatverdächtigen
nein überhaupt nicht das war und
örtliche örtliche täter aus dem bereich
kusel hat mir den tatsächlich die nichts
zu tun hat auch mit den delikten die
hier zur rede stehen nichts zu tun
oder sind sie schon aufgefangen
werden
also was wir momentan wissen ist dass
der 38 jährige haupttatverdächtige
bereits polizeilich in erscheinung
getreten ist zum einen wegen
jagdwilderei und zum anderen wegen einer
verkehrsunfallflucht
bezüglich des zweiten tatverdächtigen
wissen wir dass er polizeilichen ja
schaden getreten des wegen
betrugsdelikten aber ansonsten liegen
uns derzeit keine weitergehenden
polizeilichen erkenntnisse vor also eine
vorverurteilung gibt es nicht keiner von
von
von den beiden hat hat eine
rechtskräftige vorstrafe
castello von den sat 1 nachrichten und
zwar wurden die daten aufgezeichnet also
gab es die eine boutique m falls nein
wie wäre man auf die tatverdächtigen
gekommen wenn ich diesen personalausweis
gefunden hätte und tatort
hypothetische frage die man jetzt so
nicht beantworten kann die
ermittlungslage hätte nicht gut
ausgesehen
von der bild hallo bei den hessen aber
fotos die man gesehen hat das sieht man
ja ein mann der mets kapitel sozusagen
becker schütze war das
also im grunde zu den zu den festnahmen
bildern die in der präsident jetzt auch
keine stellung hier hier beziehen mit
der stellung
trotzdem sagen was von servustv die
frage wäre jetzt mal nach den waffen
woher stammen diese und die konnten die
in den besitz gelangen
das hat der kollege gott ja eben schon
versuch so sagen es wurden etliche
waffen gefunden in den verschiedenen
objekten und da sind wir momentan daran
uns auch den überblick haben wir aber
die waffen müssen ja ganz konkret
aufgelistet werden und müssen dann
verglichen werden mit papieren
stattlichen werden und da ist am
kommunalpolitischen ermittler gerade
dabei da kann ich jetzt endlich
definitiv noch nicht sagen
warum eine polizeianwärterin war sie
noch in ausbildung war ist es üblich
dass jemand der ausbildung war quasi als
vollwertige polizei eingesetzt werden
kann das ist die erste frage und die
zweite frage ich habe es auch nicht
richtig verstanden gibt es ausnahmen
gibt es bei dicken
aufnahmen oder was können sie dazu sagen
es gibt kein ich fange mit den letzten
neun es gibt keine body cam aufnahmen es
ist nicht grundsätzlich üblich dass
polizeianwärterin anwärterinnen und
anwärter direkt auch als zweite kraft
eingesetzt werden ist zu einer gewissen
phase des studiums ist das auch nicht
üblich dann wenn die die ausbildung zum
großteil abgeschlossen ist und dann ist
das sehr wohl auch üblichen glied dann
im ermessen der der diensthabenden
kollegen also dass dies der der
polizeiinspektion in kusel die kollegin
hier war kurz vor dem abschluss die
hätte im
[Musik]
mai ihren ihren dienst begonnen sie
hatte alle trainings schießt
trainingseinsatz trainings zugriffs
trainings absolviert die skis trainings
waren im dezember noch mal mit einer
prüfung auch abgelegt worden und so dass
das in diesem fall auch dann sie war
auch schon zweimal dem praktikum hier
beim pp west falls bei der
kriminalpolizei bei der schutzpolizei
stand als die weise fast mehr der
hinsicht eine fertige polizistin und
dann kann man das machen es waren auch
die besonderen umstände ich habe ja
gesagt das war ein zivilfahrzeug das
überwiesen der aufklärung dienen sollte
an der stelle und eigentlich nicht zur
kontrolle von fahrzeugen grundsätze
nicht vorgesehen war ich weiß auch dass
diese stelle
der ist der tatort wird das einhalten
von fahrzeugen aus dem fließenden
verkehr eigentlich nicht geeignet ist
und das gilt insbesondere auch für
das anhalten mit dem zivil fahrt mit
einem zivilfahrzeug also dass ich auch
das auch mit zu vermuten ist dass das
fahrzeug stand als die kollegen dort
hinzukommen und die was die annahme von
den beiden war das mag nun dahin
gestellt sein das ist natürlich eine
eine vermutung spekulation ob die panne
oder unfall dort anzunehmen war was wir
dort ja häufig haben in dem bereich
puzzle das sind halt eben auch
wildunfälle
ja und das kann schon mal sein dass da
an einem bild stück auf dem offenen auf
der straße liegt denn auch in ein
fahrzeug gesehen wäre dann geht man vom
bild unfall aus denn für wilderei haben
wir hier kaum ganz wenig erkenntnisse
und das ist bei uns eigentlich mit dass
keine so große rolle und wenn es eine
rolle spielt bei einzelnen delikten dann
in einer art und weise wie sie hier
nicht zur rede steht sondern ist auch
mal durch nicht fachgerechte zerlegen
von bild das sind dann die die die
straftatbestände ja also mann konnte von
dem von diesem von dieser ist von diesem
sachverhalt jetzt bei der ersten ansicht
dieses zu kontrollierenden fahrzeug ist
nicht davon ausgehen dass hier was hier
vorlage
von rtl und n tv ein zwei fragen zum
einen in welchem verhältnis stehen die
beiden verdächtigen zu in dem sie
verwandt haben wir hier schon vorher
kriminalistisch in erscheinung getreten
gemeinsam und haben sich die beiden
mittlerweile gegenüber den ermittlern
gegenüber der staatsanwaltschaft
irgendwie geäußert gibt es ähnliche
äußerungen von den beiden
hier ist bisher nur bekannt dass die
beiden bekannt sind also auf jeden fall
nicht verwandt
der ältere der beiden beschuldigten
hatte von seinem schweigerecht gebrauch
gemacht die jüngere der beiden
beschuldigten hat angaben gemacht
hat eingeräumt die wilderei dass man da
gemeinsam unterwegs war um wild zu jagen
er hat dann auch geschildert diese
kontrolle situation und die schüsse
er hat aber bestritten selbst geschossen
zu haben
dazu hat er nichts gesagt
ja also die kollegin die
hatte dass die pistole im holster
die hatte wohl möglicherweise die eine
taschenlampe vor in der hand und die
papiere möglicherweise die vag los der
kollege hat dann noch sein magazin
gelehrt also hat
14 mal noch geschossen und
der weitere ablauf den müssen wir jetzt
noch leeren
alexander dietz swr fernsehen wenn man
sagt das zivilfahrzeug war quasi am
kontrollieren ist hinterher gefahren hat
die womöglich vielleicht auch entdeckt
wo waren denn in der zeit die anderen
beiden autos der polizei wandel nah dran
man die weiter weg wie schnell waren die
werden am tatort als was passiert ist
die waren im dortigen bereich aber nicht
unmittelbar dabei sie war uns sogar acht
bis zehn minuten später waren es dann an
den ereignisort
der ard tagesschau es war in der presse
zu lesen dass die beiden polizisten
durch kopfschüsse gestorben sind was
können sie zu den schüssen sarden wurden
die waren es kopfschüsse
nachfrage die
bundesinnenministerium faeser sprach er
von einer hinrichtung was durchaus den
schluss zulässt dass es kopfschüsse sind
das kann ich bestätigen ja
das kann ich bestätigen beide sind
beides dem kopf getroffen worden
also die die polizeibeamtin das hatte
ich ja eben schon gesagt mit einem
schuss und der polizeibeamte ist viermal
getroffen worden und einen schuss gegen
auch in den kopf
angela abfahrt von der bild zwei fragen
wurden bei den tatverdächtigen drogen
gefunden und zweite frage gibt es bezüge
in die reichs bürgers thema
das erste gar nicht verneinen bisher
gibt es keine erkenntnisse von uns weiß
saarland gibt es auch keine und mit
digitalem jahren bezüglich des zweiten
bezüge zur reisberger szene oder auch
politisch motivierte kriminalität haben
wir keinerlei erkenntnis
was mich interessieren würde einer der
beiden tatverdächtigen war ja bekannt
dafür dass man konnte mir das mal im
internet lesen dass er ja seine
jagdtrophäen verkauft hat gewerblich
also das fleisch handel betrieben hat
und er hatte ja auch keine berechtigung
mehr
hatte man denn auch ausreichend seitens
der behörden nach erlöschen der
berechtigung überprüft ob er noch im
besitz einer waffe war
das können wir ihnen heute als ermittler
von der west falls ja hier nicht
beantworten das müssen die erhebung in
den nächsten tagen wir haben das ja
schon gesagt dass wir den waffen noch
aufbereitet werden muss dass muss
journalistisch aufbereitet werden um es
dann mit den behördlichen dingen in eine
übereinander gelegt werden und muss dann
festgestellt werden was da stimmt was
nicht stimmt das kann weiß nicht sagen
ich würde gerne wissen ist man am anfang
auch durchsuchungen wegen mehr leuten
ist man sicher dass sie nur zu zweit
bangen da gibt es noch ermittlungen in
der richtung dass auch mehr leute
beteiligt sein können
also wir gehen jetzt momentan von den
beiden aus es wurden in der ersten phase
natürlich auch mehrere personen
kontrolliert es wurden auch mehrere
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen durchgeführt
der doktor gehen dann eben auch gesagt
da hatte ich auch jemand gebeten das
klargestellt wird dass er nicht
verdächtig ist das ist auch so es gab
zum beispiel im bereich kirkel gab es
eine durchsuchung das ist kein kein
verdächtiger sondern das sind nur
bekannte kontaktpersonen und momentan
nach den ermittlungen gehen wir von zwei
kindern von zwei tätern aus
ich würde darüber sprechen aber diese
zwei männer 38 jahre und 32 jahre alt
was macht den 38-jährigen zum
hauptverdächtigen und auf der anderen
seite würde mich interessieren wer
meldung bekommen dass die polizisten das
auto wohl angehalten haben weil es
angeblich ohne licht unterwegs war
können sie dazu was sagen die frage
hintenan als ich habe ja gesagt dass die
diese meldung mit ohne liest kann ich
nicht kann ich nicht von dieser stelle
aus bestätigen ich gehe davon aus dass
das fahrzeug gestanden hat dass ich gehe
davon aus dass das fahrzeug stehend
angetroffen wurde von den kollegen aber
das ist eine vermutung von mir ja das
ist aus den anhaltspunkten die wir
bisher haben und die zweite wurde frage
die erste
das kann man jetzt noch nicht sagen ob
er der hauptverdächtige ist wir haben
die papiere von ihnen gefunden er war
der erste verdächtige ja also über ihn
kam man zu dem zweiten
egal wer von rpr1 nochmal zur genauen
zum genauen verständnis haben gesagt das
jagdgewehr als ein einen lager und mit
dem wurde viermal geschossen bedeutet
nach jedem schuss muss oder aktiv
nachgeladen werden wie kann man sich das
vorstellen
also ich bin jetzt kein waffenexperte
und ich glaube sie werden ja auch keinen
waffenexperten hier moment finden ich
habe mir das jetzt auch nur laienhaft
erklären lassen damit die justiz das
jetzt im ersten zugriff versteht
das eine ist eine schrotflinte die kann
man aber das ist jetzt mal eine
laienhafte auskunft so habe ich das
jedenfalls verstanden mit zwei patronen
laden mit zwei schrotpatronen
und das andere ist ein einlader
jedes mal wenn sie einen schuss
abgefeuert haben müssen sie die waffe
aufklappen und eine neue patrone
einlegen und dann können sie wieder
feiern wobei man sagen muss wir geübt
ist kann das relativ schnell
aber es ist nichts was man repetieren
kann oder nichts was halb oder
vollautomatisch funktioniert sondern man
muss händisch was tun um den nächsten
schuss abfeuern zu können
daraus schließen wir auch dass zwei
personen geschossen haben
vom zeitlichen ablauf her im moment
jedenfalls kaum vorstellbar wie kaum
vorstellbar ist dass eine person
nacheinander zwei waffen benutzt die
diese eigenschaften haben
in der dynamik des geschehens ist das im
moment kaum vorstellbar
die us-bürger zeitung wir haben die
beiden tatverdächtigen einen sitzplatz
im saarland festgenommen in einem
gebäude können sie nähere angaben machen
was für ein gebäude das ist und in
welcher verbindung das zu dem
tatverdächtigen 38-jährige steht
wenn sie fragen noch mal kurz in das
gebäude wo sie die beiden festgenommen
haben in welcher verbindung das zu den
tatverdächtigen steht und um was für ein
gebäude es sich handelt wird sie müssen
aufmerksam geworden sein
also der ursprüngliche hinweis auf die
örtlichkeit kamen durch das aufgefundene
fahrzeug das wurde im rahmen der
fahndung festgestellt dieses fahrzeug
und aufgrund unserer vorherigen
ermittlungen nämlich bezüglich bekannten
zu unserem ersten tatverdächtigen
mussten wir auch dass dort ein
unmittelbarer nähe dieser tatverdächtige
zwei wohnhaft ist und von daher konnten
wir natürlich die rückschlüsse darauf
ziehen dass sich wahrscheinlich beide
tatverdächtigen zu diesem zeitpunkt dort
in diesem komplex aufgehalten hatten es
handelt sich dabei um wohnhäuser mit
mehreren mietwohnungen
und schon sagen
ist die polizeianwärterin kurzfristig
für jemand anderen in den dienst
eingesprungen
nein das ist nicht der fall ist war
planmäßig es war der zweite dienst der
anwärterin in kusel sie war erst wenige
tage wieder von der fachhochschule
zurückgekehrt hat ein spätdienst gemacht
und planmäßig auch den nachtdienst
gemacht
situation habe ich noch nicht richtig
verstanden sie haben gesagt das auto hat
möglicherweise als das auto der
mutmaßlichen täter zustand waren die
bergab unterwegs oder bergauf unterwegs
welches fahrzeug handelte es sich um der
polizist hat geschossen hat er das
fahrzeug den rauchenden die personen
betroffen oder gar nicht oder ja wenn es
einen schusswechsel gab hat er ihn
geschossen ich habe ja gesagt das ist
was dieser tat an ablauf anbelangt dass
wir da noch im bereich der begründeten
vermutungen sind wir kennen die wir
jetzt eine vermutung die wir aufgrund
von der von der spurenlage erstmal hier
anstellen was jetzt im einzelnen dort
genau passiert ist das kann man momentan
man dafür hat noch nichts sagen da muss
man die spuren die die
kriminaltechnischen die tatortarbeit der
der vergleich der der spuren alles mal
abwarten und gegeneinander in
verhältnisse und dann hoffen wir dass
wir dann auch aufschluss darüber
bekommen was dort wirklich passiert ist
ja momentan es gibt das aussageverhalten
wie wie das ausland verhalten ist dass
wir da auch eine maßgebliche rolle dabei
spielen aber anhand der objektiven
beweislage werden wir das tatgeschehen
in den groben zügen denke ich
rekonstruieren können aber jetzt ob es
das 100 prozent gelingt das weiß ich
nicht und wir sind möglicherweise am
ende auch vielleicht der eine oder
andere kleinigkeit auch im bereich
weiter weiterhin der spekulation ja also
ob das fahrzeug jetzt gefahren ist oder
oder ob es gestanden hat ich kann nur
sagen nach meiner bewertung nach
bewährten der kollegen gehen wir davon
aus dass es schon gestanden hat und
nicht gefahren ist ja
ja das war ja das war ja die umstände
waren ja wahr denn die umstände gewesen
wie der kollege gesagt hat das war ja
über über verschiedene verbindungen von
dem ersten tag und auch zu ermöglichen
lutz hat gekommen sind das war ein
fahrzeug davon ja und er selbst hat ja
keine fahrzeuge zugelassen so dass da
einige fahrzeuge freundin von
angehörigen und freunden in den blick
geraten sind da war auch dieses fahrzeug
dabei und als das in sulzbach
festgestellt wurde hat man ja auch
gesehen dass es beschädigt war und
insofern hat dieses dieser dieser dieser
diese feststellung zu dieser fahren
drucks feststehen und sulzbach auch dann
zu einer dazu geführt dass man die die
die diese dieses fahrzeug wäre eine
vander hielt als zuvor dann haben wir
dann auch die die entsprechenden
sicherungsmaßnahmen
an dem fahrrad teilchen an dem objekt
dann auch mit unseren spezialeinheiten
vorgenommen
was man jungen dpa noch mal infrage doch
den kollegen es gab also im wagen
einschusslöcher und hat der kollege auch
jemand von den verdächtigen getroffen
mit seinen 14 schüssen
also soweit ich informiert bin haben die
haben die beiden verdächtigen keine
schussverletzungen am fahrzeug sind
allerdings schäden die mit schuss mit
mit einschließen in einklang zu bringen
sind wobei der endgegner g endgültigen
berichtet da auch noch ausstehen
mal war schon spiegel sie hatten vorhin
gesagt die sozialen verhältnisse seien
eher brüchig die wirtschaftlichen nicht
gut können sie das ein bisschen
ausführen also da ist wenn der insolvenz
des bäcker ladens die rede können sie
was zur familiensituation sagen wann das
familienväter war es nicht aber
vielleicht
entscheidung im trennung gezeigt nähere
erkenntnisse
tiefgehende angaben kann ich kann ich
nicht machen der soll getrennt gelebt
haben es war ja auch diese meldet diese
erste meldeadresse in hamburg die war ja
da gehen wir davon aus dass da noch
nicht gewohnt hat
20m verhältnissen hat er
gesagt also sicherlich gibt es noch
ermittlungen zu was wir jetzt wissen
dass so weit kann man das schon
bestätigen dass es da
saarland offensichtlich ermittlungen im
zusammenhang mit einem
insolvenzverfahren gibt oder das ist ein
insolvenzverfahren gab was den älteren
der beiden beschuldigten betrifft und
dass das möglicherweise auch
ermittlungen gibt im zusammenhang mit
insolvenz möglicherweise
betrugshandlungen aber das ist auch noch
nicht abgeklärt was
davon zu halten ist
daraufhin haben wir kurz davor fest am
ort war auch gleichzeitig der wohnort
also wohl
also einer der tatverdächtigen war dort
gemeldet der zweite tatverdächtige war
dort nicht gemeldet er war
offensichtlich mit dem ersten zusammen
der
38-jährige war nicht gemeldet
mich interessiert noch haben sie schon
erkenntnisse ob die beiden
tatverdächtigen aus dem auto
ausgestiegen waren weil es ist ja recht
schwierig aus dem auto heraus mit
langwaffen zu schießen dann noch zwei
leute also wissen was der schuss distanz
zu der tatrekonstruktion habe ich ja
schon was gesagt weitergehend erkennt
das möchte ich jetzt doch nicht
mitteilen
swr fernsehen inwieweit kann man denn
sagen dass diese bilder reihe vielleicht
auch sozusagen den haupt unterhalt
dieser beiden männer ja unterstützt hat
weil ja insolvenzverfahren da wohl an
gängig waren und sie auch seine soziale
komponente nicht gerade sehr stabil kann
man denn dann sagen dass das eventuell
ihr
täglich brot war das wird gegenstand der
ermittlungen sein es gibt schon hinweise
darauf dass da schon gewerblich und
schon auch professionell gemacht wurde
ja den der sache gehen auch nach
ich hatte noch mal eine frage an sie
herr denn die haben es eingangs gesehen
sie sind sichtlich gerührt ich denke wir
können das auch alle hier absolut
nachvollziehen aber geben sie uns doch
gerne noch mal einen kleinen einblick
was macht diese tat mit ihnen was macht
das mit den kollegen im polizeipräsidium
und eine frage an sie herr doktor
jährigen sie haben es angesprochen es
macht fassungslos wie mit teilweise mit
den vollzugsorgan umgegangen wird haben
sie gesagt beschreiben sie mal ein
bisschen was meinen sie damit und haben
sie den eindruck dass es vermehrt zu
solchen fällen kommt und das jetzt ich
sage mal das schlimmstmögliche ist aber
es auch schon unterschwellig beginnt mit
respektlosigkeit hass gegen
polizeibeamte oder andere offizielle
person wenn sie uns dazu noch versagen
könnten
ja ich mache das ganze präsidium wir
haben gestern abend ja auch zeitgleich
wären diesem ermittlungseinsatz und wenn
der zahlreichen maßnahmen die wir im
verlaufe des tages durchgeführt dann
hier beispielsweise auch
montagsspaziergänge gehabt und wenn man
durch die flure gegangen ist ich war bei
allen kolleginnen kollegen in allen
einsatzabschnitten hatten mit einem
versuch zu sprechen wenn man merkt man
eine sehr große betroffenheit
die große betroffenheit
wird bei mir persönlich davon dass ich
auch in meiner tochter ab die im
gleichen alter ist wie die verstorbene
kollegin
und darüber hinaus ist es auch so dass
der verstorbene kollege mir auch bekannt
war er hat unsere pressestelle vor
kurzem ein praktikum gemacht ein sehr
sympathischer sehr offener kollege der
für uns auch werbung gemacht hat
das betrifft ein sehr persönlich und
diese große betroffenheit ist geht über
das präsidium noch hinaus die werden sie
merken und der kompletten
rheinland-pfälzischen polizei
und ich habe es ja eingangs erwähnt wir
kriegen
solidaritätsbekundungen wir kriegen
beileidsbekundungen aus ganz europa das
hilft einem dann schon ein wenig dass
man merkt dass da so eine große
solidarität ist im übrigen auch im
gesamten einsatzablauf also alles was
wir haben wollten was wir machen wollten
das haben wir gestern machen können im
rahmen der rechtlichen möglichkeiten all
das gemacht was machbar ist und
nur dann ist es auch möglich dass man
solche ermittlungen so schnell zu ende
bringt wie wir das heute jetzt erleben
hier sitzen und wir sind ja noch in
einem sehr frühzeitigen startpunkt der
unter zeitpunkt der ermittlung es wird
noch zeitweilig zu ermitteln sein es
gibt viele aspekte die wir noch haben
die wir auch jetzt noch überprüfen
müssen auch die mehrfach angesprochene
rekonstruktion der gesamten tat abläufe
all das steht noch aus deshalb bin ich
auch ein verständnis dass wir an vielen
stellen auch heute nicht tiefer
berichten können aber es ist wirklich so
dass wir sehr stark betroffen sind und
das geht durchs gesamte präsidium noch
durch die gesamte polizei ich war heute
morgen auch bei einer der betroffene
familie die nächste familie werde ich
auch besuchen
also man hat dann schon die tränen in
den augen und man kann auch wenn man die
mutter umarmt
muss man sehr also wir hatten auch meine
innerlich bewegt hat an das geht einem
sehr nah
ja das jetzt noch mal die bewegenden
worte auch von michael denner der noch
mal seine große persönliche
betroffenheit auch zum ausdruck gebracht
hat über diese tat er hat er auch
eingangs gesagt dass sie in gedanken das
ganze polizeipräsidium westpfalz dessen
präsident er ist dass das ganze
präsidium in gedanken bei den kollegen
natürlich auch bei den angehörigen sei
das sei alles unfassbar und zu sie
würden auch eine große welle der
anteilnahme erleben wir können gerade an
der stelle vielleicht noch mal kurz auf
eure reaktionen ein bisschen
widerspiegeln auf youtube generell auch
hier unheimlich viel anteilnahme und
auch bei leid oft gehörte worte die wir
hier sehen unbegreiflich fassungslos und
grausam vielleicht lese ich mal den
einen oder anderen kommentar von israel
04 warum wird gerade bei den querdenkern
die polizei als feindbild gesehen wo
alles abgeladen werden kann
unverständlich welten kinder über
youtube wer schießt den zwei polizisten
wegen gewilderten tiere da steht auch in
keiner relation und auch petra korn über
youtube mir ist unbegreiflich wie man zu
reagieren kann unerlaubter waffenbesitz
und will 3 ist nicht toll aber deswegen
tötet man doch niemanden und in diese
richtung haben sich ganz viele von euch
geäußert wir wollen die pressekonferenz
noch mal kurz auf arbeiten mit meinem
kollegen bakterien er ist für uns vor
ort und wir haben jetzt viele
informationen bekommen bobby und nach
allem was man jetzt gehört hat was
geschildert worden ist scheint es ja so
zu sein dass es doch wilderei zumindest
war die dann dazu geführt hat dass die
beiden tatverdächtigen ihre tat
verdecken wollten und das feuer auf die
beiden polizisten die sie kontrolliert
haben eröffnet haben vielleicht kannst
du das noch ein bisschen ergänzen
zumindest gibt es tatsächlich einige
hinweise darauf dass es jetzt nicht ein
bloßer zufall war dass die
24 jährige polizistin und der 29 jahre
alte polizist die beiden tatverdächtigen
dort angetroffen haben es gab wohl den
verdacht so ging es auf der
pressekonferenz jetzt hervor auf ein
eigentumsdelikt
in dem fall offensichtlich wilderei und
dieser zivil zivile wagen mit dem die
beiden beamten unterwegs waren war dann
auch nicht alleine dort in der gegen das
war noch die rede von zwei
polizeistreifen die in acht bis zehn
minuten entfernung auch noch mit
unterwegs waren und einige infos die wir
gestern schon gelesen und gehört haben
das ist also ein funkspruch schon
gegeben haben soll in dem sich die
beiden beamten also die 24 jährige und
der 29 ring gemeldet haben und durch
gegeben haben mann habe wild tiere in
einem fahrzeug gefunden den hat es dann
offensichtlich tatsächlich gegeben und
dann halt später auch den funkspruch
dass geschossen wird vielleicht eine
sache nur eine korrektur die möchte ich
gerne noch loswerden wir haben eben in
der 14 uhr heute in deutschland gesagt
dass dieses ereignis offensichtlich
schon sonntagabend stattgefunden hat das
war tatsächlich missverständlich
ausdrückte von der polizei wurde aber
eben noch einmal korrigiert nein also um
4 uhr 20 montag früh hat sich das ganze
ereignete also am montagmorgen in aller
herrgottsfrühe bierzelt fragt uns wie
youtube sind es somit nur zwei täter
oder ist immer noch die rede von einem
dritten es war ja ursprünglich auch die
rede davon dass die fahndung immer noch
laufe aber soweit ich das jetzt richtig
verstanden habe man konzentriert sich
doch auf die beiden tatverdächtigen
ja das ist tatsächlich auch der stand
den ich jetzt habe ich habe zwar auch
heute schon meldungen gelesen dass die
fahndung jetzt eingestellt worden sei
kann ich jetzt tatsächlich ad hoc nicht
bestätigen aber die beiden
tatverdächtigen das sind die die jetzt
zur zeit im mittelpunkt stehen und die
ja auch tatsächlich schon in
untersuchungshaft sich befinden nachdem
sie heute dem haftrichter vorgeführt
worden sind wir sprechen gleich noch mit
sabrina hug und sie ist vorsitzende der
gewerkschaft der polizei in
rheinland-pfalz aber ob wir vielleicht
vorher noch an dich die frage wir hatten
schon kurz über die beiden
tatverdächtigen gesprochen 38 und 32
jahre alt sind da jetzt noch einmal neue
erkenntnisse dazu gekommen aus welchem
umfeld die beiden kamen
und kann man da vielleicht für weitere
auskünfte geben mit welchen menschen man
es da zu tun hatte
oder hat
ja also zumindest zudem zu dem 38
jährigen sowie 38 jährigen andreas s der
gestern auch namentlich zur fahndung
ausgeschrieben wurde gab es noch ein
paar vorsichtige infos also erst mal
wurde gesagt dass bei beiden nach
jetzigen zeitpunkt ein politisch
motivierter hintergrund vermutet wird
also da scheint man tatsächlich nicht
von einer politisch motivierten straftat
auszugehen bei andreas s was man gestern
auch im laufe des tages schon lesen und
hören konnte der offensichtlich auch
eine bäckerei hatte da geht es auch um
ein insolvenzverfahren das im
hintergrund läuft es gibt da
unstimmigkeiten was die was den
waffenbesitz angeht ob in denen nun
überhaupt sauber waffen besitzen durfte
oder nicht zu dem 32 jährigen ist jetzt
bekannt dass er sich wohl im vergleich
zu andreas es schon zu einigen aussagen
also zu einigen aussagen hat bewegen
lassen er hat wohl angaben gemacht zu
dem vorgang am montag um 4 uhr 20
währenddessen andreas es der 38 jährige
bisher nichts zu dem vorgang gesagt hat
was aber auch klar ist dass wurde im
laufe des tages auch schon kommuniziert
man hat halt eben waffen gefunden also
waffen über die die wahrscheinlich dann
auch für die tat vielleicht genutzt
wurden das ist natürlich jetzt alles
gegenstand der ermittlungen aber in den
in sulzbach da wo man andreas s
festgenommen hat hat man auch weitere
waffen gefunden
vielleicht das auch noch mal gerade als
ergänzung zu dem was du gesagt hast der
32-jährige also so wird es jetzt auch
inzwischen von den agenturen
kommuniziert hat bislang bestritten
selbst geschossen zu haben der 38
jährige macht noch von seinem
schweigerecht gebrauch und das war nur
dass gerade angesprochen hast auch in
bezug auf die
waffenbesitz erlaubnis sozusagen der
deutschen jagdverband hat erklärt der
38-jährige sei nicht im besitz eines
gültigen jagdschein es gewesen nach
derzeitigem kenntnisstand habe die
zuständige behörde im saarland seinen
antrag erneut einen jagdschein zu lösen
wegen fehlender zuverlässigkeit wird
abgelehnt also auch da findet ihr das
statt
weil ich so dass man ihn ohne weiteres
den schein hätte geben können
die letzte frage an dich hier geht es
jetzt weiter wurde noch mal was gesagt
jetzt der weitere verlauf ist und wie
jetzt die ermittlungen sich weiter nicht
ja also tatsächlich hat der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt noch mal gesagt dass
bei diesem verfahren eine
ganz genaue prüfung der sachverhalte des
sachverhaltes unabdingbar ist also man
werde sich hier auch nicht zu schnellen
schlüssen hinreißen lassen wer gestern
die berichterstattung verfolgt hat der
kann das ein stück weit bestätigen
dagegen relativ wenige infos gesichert
tatsächlich und bestätigt über die
behörden raus dass damit hat man dann
gewartet bis heute ein gewisser
erkenntnisstand da ist und ich glaube
das ist etwas was man jetzt mit blick
auf die weiteren ermittlungen bis hin
zur anklageerhebung und ähnliches dann
auch erwarten kann dass es hier eine
sehr genaue prüfung gibt und ein fazit
das auch am ende dieser pressekonferenz
steht das ist die noch einmal zum
ausdruck gebrachte ganz große
betroffenheit von allen beteiligten es
geht hier eben um junge kolleginnen und
kollegen der behörden hier polizisten
eine polizistin und ein polizist und das
haben hier alle stellen auch noch einmal
unterstrichen wie groß die betroffenheit
die anteilnahme ist dass diese beiden
jungen menschen in ausübung ihrer
pflicht ums leben gekommen sind
so ist es vielen dank botticelli an war
das für uns mein kollege vor ort
dankeschön für diese einschätzungen und
einordnungen und wir sprechen weiter mit
sabrina kunst sie ist vorsitzende der
gewerkschaft der polizei in rheinland
pfalz hallo frau kunst schön dass sie
bei uns sind
frau kunst die getötete polizist in
worms gehört war ja noch in der
ausbildung und die frage wurde für ihn
auch auf der pressekonferenz gestellt
ist es denn üblich dass sich
auszubildende also nur mit einem nur in
anführungszeichen weiteren kollegen auf
solchen streifen befinden und ist das
ihrer meinung nach auch richtig so
also wir haben ja eben beitrag gehört
das ist ja jetzt nicht so dass die
studierenden und studierende von beginn
an ich sag mal frisch im studium sind
sondern das studium sein duales studium
wir setzen ja gerade darauf dass im
studium berufspraktische inhalte in der
praxis an werten und mit jedem modul und
mit jedem monat des studiums haben dann
die jungen kolleginnen kollegen auch
mehr erfahrung so dass man im grunde
genommen eigentlich schon sagen muss ist
es grundsätzlich üblich dass mit den
praktikantinnen praktikanten dann in der
regel zutritt rausgefahren wird aber mit
zunehmendem studium gerade so zum ende
wie das hier bei der kollegin auch der
fall war ist es nicht unüblich dass man
dann auch mit den kollegen kollegen
alleine raus werden
jetzt ist es so dass wurde auf der
pressekonferenz gesagt und diesen tenor
finden wir auch bei unserem publikum
hier in den kommentaren es ist
bedrückend zu erleben wie viel hass und
auch gewalt der polizei entgegen schlägt
und die frage die sich auch bei uns
viele stellen ist man im 04 zum beispiel
hat sich das in der letzten zeit
verstärkt
also wir stellen ja schon seit vielen
jahren fest dass sich die umgangsformen
in bezug auf die polizei deutlich
verändert haben das hat mit verbalen
attacken und entgleisungen
begonnen über beleidigungen bis hin zu
körperlichen attacken wir stellen seit
vielen jahren wobei man auch dazusagen
muss dass ja noch gar nicht so lange
statistisch erfasst wird wie viele
übergriffe auf polizisten und polizisten
gibt wir machen das allerdings jetzt
seit einigen jahren und stellen auch in
rheinland-pfalz kontinuierlich fest dass
die statistik tatsächlich nach oben gilt
ja der gleiche fragesteller fragt dann
auch weiter wie kann man die polizei
bald spürbar verbessern so dass es bei
ihren kolleginnen und kollegen auch
ankommt
also muss im grunde glaube ich jetzt an
der stelle ein bisschen aufpassen was
man aus dieser sehr dramatischen
brutalen tat der die kolleginnen und der
kollege sprichwörtlich auch erschossen
worden sind es gestern ja auch von einer
hinrichtung gesprochen worden dass man
daraus jetzt nicht insgesamt die
falschen rückschlüsse zieht insofern bin
ich auch sehr dankbar dass
öffentlichkeit auch die medien und
insbesondere auch das polizeipräsidium
westpfalz sehr zurückhaltend mit der
situation umgeht und auch nur die
gesicherten erkenntnisse dann auch der
öffentlichkeit vorgestellt werden
es wäre jetzt glaube ich viel zu früh
und auch falsch deswegen sind wir auch
mit gewerkschaftlichen forderungen
aktuell sehr zurückhaltend für den
moment gewerkschaftliche forderungen
rauszugeben sondern man muss jetzt am
ende den genauen geschehensablauf sobald
man das rekonstruieren kann abwarten um
dann zu schauen was bedeutet das jetzt
eigentlich in bezug auf das taktische
vorgehen das die annäherung an fahrzeuge
betrifft et cetera pp was bedeutet das
aber auch in bezug auf die aus und
fortbildung und ist insgesamt die
ausstattung auch ausreichend für den
moment muss man sagen wir sind in
rheinland-pfalz gerade wegen des
phänomens gewalt gegen polizeibeamte in
den letzten jahren kontinuierlich besser
ausgestattet worden wir haben vielleicht
denken die body kämen wir haben den bike
also den taser in rheinland pfalz im
einsatz aber soweit ich das geschehen
beurteilen kann natürlich mit viel
abstand ich war noch nicht vor ort da
kann man glaube ich in der situation
aber schon sagen die kolleginnen kollege
hätten noch besser ausgebildet sein
können die ausstattung möglicherweise
noch besser sein können wir aus wenn man
dann an der stelle an schutzausstattung
auch tragen ich glaube man hätte die tat
am ende möglicherweise nicht verhindern
können ja weil sie eben in dem fall dann
doch einfach so brutal und auch nicht zu
erwarten gewesen ist sie haben daher
noch mal die body camps angesprochen
darauf werden wir auch in unserem forum
öfter mal noch mal hingewiesen oder
gefragt waren die im einsatz hat man
dadurch irgendwelche erkenntnisse
gewinnen können wissen sie davon
da kann ich ihnen tatsächlich nicht zu
sagen also ich weiß nicht ob die
kolleginnen kollegen body kämen getragen
haben und wenn sie getragen wurde ob sie
auch eingeschaltet war ich bin mir aber
ziemlich sicher wenn das der fall
gewesen sein sollte dann werden die
daten auch ausgewertet ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe jetzt in dem
bericht auch viele neue dinge eben
gehört das macht natürlich auch mit mir
persönlich vieles wenn man das hört und
versucht sich vorzustellen wie die
geschehensablauf gewesen sein müssen
dass menschen dann auch möglicherweise
munition 1 nachgeladen haben um da auf
menschen auf eine polizistin und einen
jungen polizisten zu schießen dann kann
ich das nicht in worte fassen und ich
muss ich muss ich noch ganz ehrlich
sagen da wird einem schlecht da ist man
ganz betroffen und das ist einfach nicht
in worte zu fassen ich lese gerade noch
mal ein paar kommentare hier unsere
userinnen und user forum schreibt eine
zunehmende verrohung bis hin zu hass und
hetze gegen ordnungskräfte setzt die
hemmschwelle zu widerstand immer weiter
herab da ist es vollkommen egal welches
motiv diese täter hatten und den meyer
schreibt diese tat hat signalwirkung
jetzt muss man bei jeder
verkehrskontrolle angst haben polizei
wird nun vorsichtiger seien diejenigen
im auto sitzend und polizisten müssten
jetzt mit mulmigem gefühl leben wie
schätzen sie das ein wie wird so eine
tat mit ihren kolleginnen oder was wird
sie dort aus lassen wenn jetzt wieder
verkehrsmäßige routinekontrollen im
prinzip bevorstehen
für den moment kann man glaube ich sagen
das ist doch so dass was in den letzten
stunden bei mir persönlich auch
angekommen ist das ist zunächst mal die
tiefe trauer die rheinland pfalz
irgendwas weise erschüttert innerhalb
der kollegenschaft also man muss mit dem
gefühl jetzt auch erstmal klar kommen
ich glaube die kollegen kollegen ganz
man verdienen dass auch da mal in ruhe
mit ihren gefühlen alleine zu sein oder
sich in der kunden timor auszutauschen
die zweite frage ist natürlich wie geht
man jetzt in einzelnen situationen damit
und ich hab gestern noch mit kollegen
gesprochen die den nachtdienst begonnen
haben jetzt sich unbedingt in der
betroffenen region aber im land mit sehr
jungen kollegen auch gesprochen die mir
schon auch gesagt haben dass er jetzt
mit einem sehr guten gefühl nach dienst
beginnen dass man auch eine sehr
betroffene stimmung wahrnimmt und wenn
ich mir auch selbst noch mal versuchen
erinnerung zu rufen weil wir das bei mir
jetzt wäre da gehen einem sehr viele
gedanken durch den kopf bei mir selbst
auch ganz viele situationen einfallen in
denen ich verkehrskontrollen
durchgeführt habe wo man dann denkt
menschen genauso auch passieren können
gerade in den ländlichen regionen hier
in rheinland pfalz ist ja so ein
waldgelände wie wir dass dort jetzt in
den bildern sehen nicht ganz unüblich
und ich glaube schon dass viele kollegen
kollegen jetzt mit ganz mulmiges gefühl
ihren dienst machen und wir haben
natürlich aufgrund des
generationenwechsels und der starken
einstellungs jahrgänge die wir in
rheinland pfalz zu verzeichnen haben
auch ein großteil der kolleginnen
kollegen im streifendienst die unter 30
jahre alt sind die sich jetzt auch noch
immer mit sicherheit noch mal im
besonderen gedanken machen wie sie
zukünftigen dienst machen nun wie sie
sich in solche situationen begeben
würden sie denn sagen dass man sich da
irgendwie anders verhalten kann sie
hatten vorhin schon angesprochen bei so
einer konkreten situationen kann man
eventuell sich gar nicht richtig
schützen
also es hat echt schwierig die konkreten
geschehensabläufe irgendwie noch mal für
sich so
zu hinterfragen oder zu überlegen die
kann hat jetzt im grunde genommen dort
abgelaufen sein wenn dann auch jetzt in
dem bericht eben geschildert wurde dass
die kolleginnen vor dem fahrzeug
aufgefunden worden ist und dann auch die
personenbezogen papiere dort aufgefunden
wurden sind das deutet ja ein bisschen
darauf hin dass die personenkontrolle am
laufen war dann möglicherweise hat dann
jemand auch auf sie geschossen ich
glaube nicht dass die kollegin der
situation die chance gehabt hätten das
irgendwie abzuwenden
sprechen wir gerade noch mal über die
situation mit den waffen offenbar wurde
ein ziemliches waffenarsenal
sichergestellt
haben sie jetzt über den fall hinaus den
eindruck dass es in deutschland
vielleicht zu leicht ist an waffen zu
gelangen oder würden sie sagen das lässt
sich jetzt so anhand dieses falles nicht
sagen
fällt mir jetzt tatsächlich schwer das
realistischen vernünftige einzuschätzen
wir hatten anrainer falls jetzt in den
letzten knapp zwei jahren ja ziemlich
dramatische ereignisse neben dem jetzt
für uns als gewerkschaft schlimmste was
man sich vorstellen kann mit das hat in
idar oberstein und der amokfahrt im
trierer bereich ich glaube man muss
schon festhalten das ja der zugriff zur
waffen mit sicherheit jetzt auch noch
mal eine ganz intensive frage sein wird
mit der gesellschaft und politik sich
auseinandersetzen muss aber die viel
spannendere frage ist natürlich auch
unter welchen umständen greifen menschen
zu einer waffe um auf andere menschen zu
schießen wenn man jetzt auch hört das
haben sie ja eben auch in einem zitat
wiedergegeben was hier im verhältnis
zueinander
zu sehen ist auf der einen seite der
vorwurf der jagdwilderei und auf der
anderen seite das töten von zwei
menschen da kann man am ende eigentlich
nur festhalten dass es hier überhaupt
nicht im verhältnis gestanden hat und
dass menschen
mit den bekannten umständen die uns
bekannt sind halt eben auf andere
menschen geschossen haben und den
verlauf unserer kollegen ja also ein
tragisches hat sabrina hug und zwar das
für uns von der gewerkschaft der polizei
in rheinland-pfalz ganz herzlichen dank
und ich kann ihnen nur noch mal mit
geben dass also die anteilnahme auch bei
uns im publikum riesengroß ist auch bei
uns natürlich in der redaktion aber das
versteht sich ja von selbst dankeschön
dass sie sich die zeit genommen haben
uns für dieses gespräch zur verfügung
stand haben danke sehr
ja und auch an euch nochmal der dank für
eure kommentare und auch für die ja
wirklich muss man sagen große
anteilnahme was diesen fall angeht wir
informieren natürlich informieren euch
natürlich weiter im laufe des tages über
die weiteren ermittlungsergebnisse so
ist da noch mal einen neuen stand geben
sollte das war es jetzt für das erste
von uns wie gesagt dankeschön für eure
kommentare einen schönen tag und bis zum
nächsten mal